et vous êtes l'avocat qu'on voit à la
télé ouais mais désolé les gars je suis
un peu je sais ce que vous vous dites le
parking encore
l'avocat de la défense le plus sexy de
Los Angeles tu parles de ce stupide
magazine
tu sais que je me fiche de tous ces
trucs
la semaine dernière vous avez fait
combien d'interviews je vais très bien
c'est rien qu'un peu de presse il y a
pas de quoi se monter la tête
Lisa
[Musique]
pour tout dire on est un peu sous l'eau
ici
paperasse d'accord maintenant qu'on est
tous là on peut commencer il va falloir
qu'on soit tous au taquet si je continue
à faire des nuits blanches on devra me
porter jusqu'à l'hôtel enfin bref
envoie-moi l'adresse
j'ai besoin d'aide on a un problème
de te le dire mais c'est pour ton
intelligence que je t'ai appelé si je
suis bon qu'à ça j'ai de très bons
souvenirs de tes talents en en reparlera
[Musique]
vous adorez que les yeux soient braqués
sur vous
allô
[Musique]
présenter laisse-moi deviner
ces gâteaux tu as roses ça donne et elle
frappe ta poitrine de bœuf j'ai pas le
temps de jouer
[Musique]